commercial loggers in the largest
indigenous forest in Kenya rushed to
beat the deadline to harvest exotic
trees
this follows the recently lifted ban on
logging at these tree plantations Cyprus
trees planted more than 20 years ago are
felt ready to be sold for Timber to go
around but we are monitoring what's
happening on the ground and working with
the government to ensure indigenous
trees like Cedar are not felt but what
we are currently talking about is exotic
trees that are planted for Timber
harvesting so this is a lot of waste
Samuel osei shows us a 33 year old Pine
Plantation that is going to waste as a
result of windfalls
the trees are meant to be cut down when
they mature to allow new trees to be
planted today we have what you call the
Pari agreement the Pari agreement which
Kenya sentenced to
has it that we have to have our carbon
sinks rights
and when we have our carbon sinks this
can only assist when you remove
plantations then you plant the new the
new
young plantations
the government imposed the logging ban
in 2018 to stop deforestation
since then Forest cover has increased
significantly by the country's Forest
Service Agency says it has lost more
than 200 million dollars in the last
five and a half years we're talking
about trees that have now matured and
are ready to be harvested or they'll die
but environmentalists are concerned
about the impact if this is not properly
regulated
these are Elders from the ogiek a Forest
community that helps protect indigenous
trees such as Syrah and others that have
grown here for hundreds of years
the law in theory is sound but the
problem in some decision makers
manipulate the roles for their own
interest all Forest stakeholders should
work together to keep the forest safe
back at the plantation Forest workers
Mark the trees that are being tracked
away for sale this stump shows that what
has been found is legal approved and not
indigenous but many doubt the new
government policy they argue the ban
should be reinstated to keep protecting
Kenya's trees Catherine soy Al Jazeera
Eastern Mao Forest Kenya